voilà monsieur bonsoir sacrifiant à la
tradition puisque d'actualité nous le
permet à la veille de ce long week-end
de pâques nous commencerons par les
prévisions de la météorologie qui
intéresse tous ceux qui ont la chance de
pouvoir partir et aussi les autres
laurent vous mais nous sommes tout oui
mais à côté daniel du pot temps du
soleil je pense pour ce week-end avec
toutefois la nécessité de conserver des
tricots tarifaire très fraîche je
m'explique si vous promener au dessus de
la france est un baromètre vous trouvez
des pressions très haute
beau temps c'est un anticyclone une zone
de beau temps qui s'étend depuis site de
l'espagne jusqu'au nord de la grande
bretagne
partout la du soleil mais attention
l'heure tourne autour dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre et regarder sur
l'est de la france
il descend venant du nord du vent est
également de leur un peu plus instable
qui apporte encore quelques nuages des
cumulus des nuages comme les quelques
averses sous ces nuages averses de pluie
parfois assez fort avec des rafales de
vent et même averses de neige en
montagne
et puis comme c'est une luce peuvent
également grandi à devenir des
cumulonimbus alors on a des orages
ça c'est dans l'est du pays donc un
temps un peu instable avec encore
quelques nuages et du vent mistral très
fort dans la vallée du rhône et sur les
côtes méditerranéennes tramontane
également mais du soleil qui poussera
les nuages dans ces régions reste du
pays maintenant tout une grande moitié
ouest
beaucoup de soleil demain pas trop de
problème si ce n'est le matin où il y
aura des brumes et même un petit peu de
brouillard dans les vallées en aquitaine
dans le centre et dans l'ouest mais ça
se dégagera dans la journée les
températures proches de 0° souffle
souvent dans la matinée au lever du jour
dans l'intérieur mais elles remonteront
vers 12 13 14 15 degrés dans la journée
avec le soleil ça c'est le temps
vendredi pour samedi mon travail est
très simple ce soir c'est le même un
anticyclone c'est une d'ozone d'air
stable et bien elle restera là et je
pense que les amateurs de pluie s'il y
en a faudrait qu'ils attendent sans
doute lundi pour ressortir leurs
parapluies
merci laurent si les anticyclones sont
de notre côté tout va bien
restons dans le domaine des vacances
après le rendez vous manqué d'hier entre
le président de la république et les
élus bretons venus manifester à paris
pour protester contre la pollution leurs
côtes
monsieur soissons le ministre du
tourisme a annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures pour essayer de sauver la saison
touristique de la bretagne notamment
terminé le plus tôt possible
les travaux de nettoiement le point avec
françois quand les plages bretonnes
seront entièrement nettoyée avant l'été
la sncf accordera de réduction de 40%
pendant le mois de juin pour promouvoir
le tourisme en bretagne les hôteliers
appliqueront des tarifs inférieurs de 15
à 20 % toujours durant mois de juin des
actions ponctuelles sont envisagées pour
aider les communes particulièrement
touchés par la marée noire
perros guirec notamment et trégastel
c'est ce qu'annoncé hier jean pierre
soisson aux élus bretons venus à paris
près de 600 de ses élus professionnels
de la mer et du tourisme des côtes du
nord est du finistère ont manifesté dans
les rues de la capitale
deux de leurs représentants venus
demander audience au président de la
république ont refusé de rencontrer le
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
qui se proposaient de les recevoir les
manifestants bretons sont rentrés chez
eux
entre temps le président de la
république faisait savoir qu'il était
disposé à les recevoir en bretagne bon
nombre de maires mécontents de leur
journée dans la capitale avec les crs
rendez vous manqués ont décidé le blocus
administratif les mairies ne seront plus
à la disposition de l'administration
nous serons les dossiers qui ne laisse
pas nous intéresser
et croyez-moi quand on prenait bien
l'administration on peut gêner beaucoup
un exemple un exemple les demandes de
renseignements les échevins de
statistiques émanant de la préfecture
le remplit de réponse à l'étranger au
tchad on estime à 3000 le nombre des
blessés en deux jours de combats ou n'a
aucune idée mais main précise du nombre
des morts qui serait toutefois très
important la ville de n'djaména a
continué à se vider de sa population au
fur et à mesure que les combats
s'intensifient pendant ce temps à paris
s'est ouverte aujourd'hui la conférence
interministérielle franco africaine
préparatoire du prochain sommet des
chefs d'état africains bien que cette
conférence soit en principe consacrée
essentiellement aux problèmes
économiques
on a bien sûr parlé du tchad représentée
par son ministre de la justice qui
déclare que le chef de l'état actuel
monsieur goukouni n'a pas reçu l'appui
de la libye je crois avoir entendu
effectivement que la radio libyenne
avait parlé d'un appel du président
goukouni à la libye mais je pense que
cela se situe uniquement au niveau de la
radio libyenne
ça ne concerne que cette radio en ce qui
me concerne elle en ce qui concerne le
gouvernement d'union nationale de
transition
il n'y a pas eu d'appel du président
goukouni à la libye vous avez vous-même
état aujourd'hui d'une aide qui pourrait
apporter en revanche sur troupe de
monsieur sénat vrai oui c'est étiez-vous
c'est exact je les dis clairement je
crois une première occasion que en ce
moment hissène habré a reçu du matériel
militaire en provenance de l'egypte et
qui est passé par un pays voisin du
tchad
on pense à quel pays précisément le
matériel est venue de l'egypte aurait
jeté pas dire par quel pays il est passé
je pense que ça c'est des vignes prenez
s'agir du soudan
c'est possible
monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui que
représentait vous et qui représentait
d'abord je viens assister à la
conférence franco africaine en tant que
représentant du gouvernement d'union
nationale de transition qui aujourd'hui
au tchad et la seule égalité mais est ce
que dans ce pays qui déchirée divisée
être ministre encore une signification
absolument ça une signification dans la
mesure où aujourd'hui je porte la voix
de ce gouvernement à l'extérieur et dans
cette conférence
j'apporte à mon sens quelque chose ne
serait que sur le plan de l'information
vous étiez encore au tchad quelle est la
situation sur le terrain quand j'ai
quitté le tchad la situation n'a pas
tellement évolué sur le plan militaire
donc chaque tendance à garder en quelque
sorte ses positions mais toujours est il
que les troupes de
six ans après était pratiquement
encerclés au centre de la ville par les
troupes du président goukouni par les
troupes du front
le front d'action commune et également
dans la partie sud de la ville par les
forces du colonel comme gay pourtant les
observateurs sur place au tchad donne
l'impression que les forces de musiciens
prix ont tendance à l'emporter ron
walker
je pense que c est un point une vue qui
a été souvent exprimé malheureusement à
travers la presse française en
particulier et je me demande de quoi
tient ce sentiment particulier vis-à-vis
des troupes de monsieur hissène habré
mais toujours est il que sur le terrain
les troupes de hissène habré subissent
des revers important décisif important
quand j'ai quitté le tchad ou
j'ajouterai simplement que ce matin à
l'ouverture de la conférence africaine
monsieur jean-françois français a
exprimé des voeux pour que le tchad puis
se retrouver rapidement la paix civile
sans laquelle aucun projet de
développement ne peut sortir demain
monsieur jean françois poncet doit tenir
une conférence de presse sur ce thème
mais déjà aujourd'hui monsieur giscard
d'estaing le président de la république
s'est entretenu à conférer avec le
général mairie chef d'état major des
armées
monsieur bourges le ministre des armées
pour donner les consignes très strictes
aux forces françaises qui réside
actuellement qui sont stationnés au
tchad
ces consignes sont au nombre de trois se
regrouper à l'écart des combats éviter
tout affrontement à tout prix et
accentuer l'aide humanitaire avec le nom
du parti communiste italien qui
intervient après celui de l'espagne est
celui de la yougoslavie la conférence
sur la paix et le désarmement que
voulait organiser le parti communiste
français et le parti ouvrier unifié
polonais semblent devoir avorter comme
l'avait indiqué li guo slave elle les
italiens pensent que cette rencontre
servirait seulement à la propagande
soviétique
pas de véritable réaction encore du
parti communiste français dans le
secrétaire général monsieur georges
marchais est actuellement en voyage à
madagascar où il a notamment dénoncé ce
qu'il appelle l'impérialisme français
qui entretient des bases militaires dans
toute cette région du monde en bref
encore résumée par philippe rochot le
reste de l'actualité à l'étranger est
d'abord la crise gouvernementale en
belgique
crise ouverte en belgique en effet le
gouvernement de monsieur martens donne
sa démission
les chrétiens sociaux flamands ont en
effet rejeté le projet de
régionalisation sur le futur statut de
bruxelles qui n'offrirait pas assez de
garanties aux flamands
dany sadr chef de l'état iranien en
minorité après le discours il annonçait
le transfert des otages américains aux
autorités légales le conseil de la
révolution estime que la réponse
américaine aux exigences de l'iran n'est
pas assez clair les otages devront
encore attendre
atmosphère des minutes à bristol en
grande-bretagne la police affronte
pendant six heures de jeunes jamaïcains
dans leur ghetto 25 blessés dont 19
policiers
les incidents ratio se multiplient les
travailleurs immigrés sont plus de 2
millions en angleterre attentat à la
bombe au salvador après les quarante
morts de dimanche dernier
les processions de pâques sont annulés
la plupart des magasins fermés
la ville pratiquement désert l'ancien
chef de la police a échappé à un
enlèvement
pas de trêve pour la semaine sainte
à l'étranger encore une information
venant d'italie retour du parti
socialiste italien au pouvoir il va
participer au prochain gouvernement qui
doit être formé à la fin de cette
semaine le parti socialiste n'avait pas
participé à un gouvernement en alliance
avec la démocratie chrétienne chrétienne
pardon depuis maintenant plus de six ans
en france l'un des événements de cette
journée c'était la présence de monsieur
georges séguy à antenne 2 me dit
monsieur séguy qui a bien sûr réagi en
priorité aux plans d'économies d'énergie
et de diversification des sources
d'énergie
présenté hier par le gouvernement il se
réjouit bien sûr de la remise au goût du
jour de l'énergie charbon demandé depuis
très longtemps par la cgt cela dit le
plan du gouvernement prévoyant plutôt
une augmentation des importations plus
une réouverture une réactivation des
mines françaises sur ce point monsieur
séguy n'est plus du tout d'accord il
estime vous allez l'entendre comme le
spécialiste économique du parti
communiste messieurs philippe herzog ce
matin dans l'humanité qu'aucune
fermeture depuis ne toléra je suis
d'accord philippe herzog
aucune fermeture depuis il est tolérable
j'observe que le gouvernement et avec
lui un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques et de syndicalistes même qui
nous accusait dans les années 50 d'être
retardataires et conservateur en
défendant le charbon en luttant contre
la fermeture des puits de mine ont
changé de ton aujourd'hui et de discours
ils reconnaissent sous l'effet des
conséquences des prix du pétrole les
perspectives de la chaire d'assèchement
des gisements pétrolifères que le
charbon est une source d'énergie tout à
fait valable il ne faisant leur français
ils ne font pas leur autocritique en
corvée j'espère que ça viendra qu'ils
reconnaîtront ils ont eu tort de nous
lancer la pierre il n'y a pas si
longtemps encore que le gouvernement
français envoyé ses forces policières
contre les mineurs qui luttait contre la
fermeture depuis
oui le charbon français oui pour
monsieur séguy le charbon france est
aussi rentable que celui l'allemagne
fédérale que nous contribuons toujours
selon lui par le biais de la communauté
européenne a financé pour monsieur séguy
il s'agit donc là d'une aberration
économique c'est le contribuable
français qui payent
continue à mettre au chômage des mineurs
français tandis qu'on achète du charbon
à l'étranger monsieur georges séguy
propose en outre au ministre de
l'industrie monsieur giraud qui étaient
là hier soir sur ce plateau un débat sur
la politique charbonnières et
énergétique de la france
parmi les autres réponse du secrétaire
général de la cgt le projet de loi sur
l'actionnariat est une duperie la lutte
contre le travail au noir à propos
duquel vous savez le président de la
chambre de commerce monsieur de
l'arrosoir remis un rapport au président
de la république georges séguy estime
qu'il s'agit là d'un serpent de mer qui
n'existerait pas si les salariés étaient
mieux payés revenu familial à 4200
francs d'essayer décidé hier par le
gouvernement
mesures insuffisantes et injuste pour
monsieur séguy la cfdt estimant de son
côté qu'il s'agit là avant tout d'une
opération électorale en fin politique à
propos de l'afghanistan ni approbation
ni condamnation pour monsieur georges
séguy à faire marcher là monsieur s'est
glissée déclarait peut-être pour la
première fois vraiment très nettement
scandalisé par les attaques contre le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
français
manufrance les choses s'arrangent le
travail a repris et le pdg a trouvé un
investisseur et 10 millions de francs
pour relancer l'entreprise jean claude
renault ces dix millions 4 millions
emporté par l' agence de publicité
publie service c'est l'investisseur tant
attendu et 6 millions accordés par
l'état sont plus qu un ballon d'oxygène
pour menu france le lancement du nouveau
catalogue avait épuisé la trésorerie de
la manu et nice et fournisseurs ni les
banques ne lui faisait plus crédit
chacun attendait qu'un investisseur se
manifeste pour que l'état débloque les 6
millions promis c'est maintenant chose
faite
en retardant la paye du mois de mars le
pdg a provoqué une grève de 24 heures
hier
mais il a aussi et surtout accélérer le
dénouement de la situation au ministère
des finances à paris avec 10 millions de
plus il devrait redonner confiance aux
fournisseurs et aux banques dont les
syndicats ont dénoncé l'attitude hier en
occupant une agence de saint-etienne
en bref encore la fédération nationale
des mutuelles des travailleurs deux
millions cinq cent mille adhérents
appellent à une manifestation le 18
avril prochain devant le ministère de la
santé pour protester à son tour contre
le projet de loi visant à instituer à un
ticket modérateur pour les mutuelles
le syndicat général de l'éducation
nationale lance un appel à l'unité au
syndicat national des instituteurs et
professeurs de collège le sni pour
lutter en commun contre la politique du
gouvernement pour faire aboutir les
revendications sur la carte scolaire les
fermetures de classes et les conditions
de travail
alors qu'on attend toujours les
conclusions du rapport confié à monsieur
giraudet le pdg d'air france sur le
thème du temps de travail la cfdt a
présenté aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de propositions tendant à démontrer par
exemple qu'une réduction de 5 heures du
temps de travail hebdomadaire peut être
créatrice de nombreux emplois ce que
conteste le cnp isabelle des chenilles
578 services d'entreprise interrogés par
la cfdt constate que chez les ouvriers
posté le gain en emploi serait de 10,8
pour cent dans la métallurgie
mais tous les postes ne se ressemblent
pas pour un ouvrier edf par exemple
seguin ne serait que de six et demi pour
cent dans le cas d'un employé de bureau
et pour la même réduction de 5 heures
hebdomadaires
les cadres cfdt consulter dans l'
enquête ont calculé lui pour cent de
création d'emplois possible pour les
cadres dont la durée du travail
hebdomadaire est souvent plus longue que
pour les employés le besoin d'emplois
supplémentaires serait de 7 % et de 9
pour les techniciens les ingénieurs et
les cadres sont intéressés au premier
chef car ce sont eux qui auraient
éventuellement à mettre en oeuvre une
telle réduction du temps de travail et à
réorganiser leurs services que nous
avons interrogés pour ne pas gêner
rijkaard ceux qui quotidiennement gère
les services et les ateliers pour leur
demander si une réduction massive du
temps praille créer l'emploi
ils nous ont répondu
massivement que oui et en qui les
concerne ce que les cadres au travail
trop effectivement il fonde en moyenne
45 heures par semaine quatre cadres
cadres sur dix se fonde la 45 eur mêmes
traits de 2 sur 10 au delà de 50 ans
qu'elles vont être leurs revendications
bon en grande majorité ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est effectivement moins une
réduction durable de manière qu'une
réduction durée annuelle que ça soit
comptabilisé en nombre d'heures de
travail ou en nombre de jours oui la
question qui reste fondamentale et qui
est posée elle par le cnpf est de savoir
si on réduit la durée du travail doit
aussi réduire les salaires ou sinon
comment l'entreprise va t'elle pays
politique que le parlement français à
fixer l'ordre du jour de sa session de
printemps les députés examineront dans
l'ordre la loi d'orientation agricole
deuxième lecture du texte un texte sur
l'actionnariat dans l'entreprise et un
projet de loi sur la notion du viol un
programme d etat blement très éclectique
sondage traditionnel figaro magazine
sofres baisse de trois points de la cote
de confiance de monsieur giscard
d'estaing pour le mois dernier georges
marchais et jacques chirac sont en
hausse d'un point tandis que raymond
barre et jacques chaban delmas sont les
grands perdants avec quatre points en
baisse à faire de breuil à la leur des
nouvelles informations publiées par le
canard enchaîné la famille de monsieur
de breuil souhaite un supplément
d'information quant à monsieur
poniatowski qui était au moment en
assassinat ministre de l'intérieur son
entourage a fait savoir aujourd'hui
qu'il n'avait jamais eu connaissance
d'un éventuel projet de meurtre
je vous rappelle que le directeur de la
police judiciaire monsieur ducret a
déclaré lui qu'il avait verbalement tenu
le juge d'instruction de la sphère au
courant des menaces qui pesait sur la
vie de monsieur de coin le procureur de
la république de grenoble a fait savoir
à monsieur gérard nicoud leader des
commerçants du side in attic qui lui
était désormais définitivement interdit
d'exercer un quelconque une quelconque
responsabilité syndicale c'est du moins
ce qu'on annonce au siège du cidunati
cette décision intervient en raison des
différentes condamnations qui depuis dix
ans ont frappé monsieur gérard nicoud qu
est d'ailleurs encore actuellement pour
quatre mois en prison avant de passer au
dossier de notre journal d'où ce soir
simplement une dernière dépêche
inquiétant quand on parle
comme en ce moment de pollution après la
sphère du tanio en effet on vient
d'apprendre à l'instant qu'un pétrolier
libérien 209 mille tonnes il est même
très important a explosé aujourd'hui
même au large des côtes de la tanzanie
c'est ce qu'annonce la société
d'assurances lloyd à londres trente sept
hommes d'équipage ont été secourus par
un autre pétrolier pour l'instant six
autres sont portés manquants nous
n'avons pas d'autres informations le
dossier de notre journal ce soir donc
l'afghanistan au moment où deux sources
pakistanaises on annonce une grande
offensive de printemps des troupes
soviétiques contre les principaux points
d'appui les rebelles afghans
nous proposons nous un reportage d envoi
nos envoyés spéciaux bernard benyamin et
patrice du tertre
les premiers journalistes de télévision
être entré en afghanistan depuis très
longtemps et qui après s'être introduits
à l'intérieur de l'afghanistan par la
frontière pakistanaise se sont retrouvés
au milieu d'un groupe de rebelles
bloqués par des blindés soviétiques
c'est le récit de leur séjour au milieu
de ces rebelles qu'il vous présente ce
soir
nous roulons depuis des heures toujours
de nuit pour éviter de nous faire
repérer par un hélicoptère soviétique
qui n'aurait pas hésité à nous bombarder
nous dormons le jour dans des relais de
montagne et à la tombée de la nuit
nous reprenons la route ou plutôt la
piste qui devait nous mener en hasard à
jack en hasard hadja c'est-à-dire au
centre de l'afghanistan une région
peuplée par 5 millions de personnes
qu'elles les chars soviétiques impose un
véritable blocus économique
le seul moment dangereux de notre
expédition est constituée par le passage
à pied de la route kaboul kandahar une
heure de marche a découvert la nuit mais
il n'y aura pas de problème nous avait
assuré nous guident la nuit les russes
ne sorte pas sur les routes afghanes
en fait les problèmes nous allions les
rencontrer beaucoup plus tôt en arrivant
au petit matin dans le premier camp des
moudjahidine en afghanistan il nous
restait à ce moment-là huit heures de
voyage avant d'atteindre la zahran jatte
et nous avions quitté pau et à la
capitale du baloutchistan pakistanais
depuis près de trois jours
nous sommes ici abadie l'un des nombreux
camps de moudjahidine dispersés sur les
hauts plateaux dominant la route kaboul
kandahar une batterie antiaérienne
protège le camp mais il faut bien le
dire
elle n'a jamais servi jusqu'à présent
les soviétiques sont occupés pour le
moment beaucoup plus au nord dans la
vallée du kunar qu'ils nettoient de fond
en comble dans les jours qui viennent
ils s'attaqueront au nouristan est ainsi
région après région à l'aide du napalm
et des gaz à la technique et des
parachutistes
le rouleau compresseur soviétique
pacifique l'afghanistan en fait personne
ne se fait beaucoup d'illusions ici jour
où l'armée rouge décidera de
s'intéresser au camp en quelques
secondes tout sera rasée pour cette
raison et moudjahidine ne se sont pas
véritablement installée à abadie c'est
une base d' attaque où il en aucun cas
le refuge
notre départ est fixé pour la fin de
l'après midi mais afin d'éviter toute
surprise
notre guide préfère envoyé en éclaireur
moudjahidine à moto mission s'assurer
que la voie est libre
moins d'une heure plus tard notre
éclaireur est de retour accueilli par
une dizaine de geri afghans venus aux
nouvelles
que se passe-t-il exactement
il est des tanks russes qui arrivent par
ici
cet homme a vu 42 charrues c'est plus de
30 camions pleins de soldats qui
bloquent la piste à quelques kilomètres
je crois que cette nuit ils vont tous
allés là-bas se battre contre les russes
et les chasser de la région moins de
deux heures plus tard arrivée dans le
camp on ne sait trop commun les cinq
chefs moudjahidines les plus importants
de la région se réunissent il ya dans
cette pièce les représentants de 30000
moudjahidine trente mille combattants de
l'offre aux premières surprises
l'afghanistan est aujourd'hui découpé en
wilayate de la taille d'un département
français environ
placée sous la responsabilité d'un seul
homme deuxième surprise il est dans
cette pièce des chefs pachtoune la tribu
dominante en afghanistan mais aussi des
hasards à leurs vieux rivaux de religion
chiite
l'intervention soviétique a favorisé le
rapprochement des deux frères ennemis
c'est en tout cas la première
manifestation tangible des accords
conclus à peshawar il ya deux mois entre
les principales organisations de
résistance
la discussion va se poursuivre une heure
durant
et comme l'on pouvait s'y attendre les
chefs décident d'attaquer les chars
soviétiques pas le choix entre les
russes et nous c'est un peu comme entre
l'eau et le feu
l'un doit attaquer l'autre et s'en
débarrasser pour toujours alors nous
allons les attaquer et nous sommes prêts
les poursuivre jusqu'à à samarcande s'il
le faut mais je vous préviens tout de
suite vous ne pourrez pas nous
accompagner vous êtes pour nous plus
utile vivant prêt à témoigner de tout ce
que vous avez vu ici que mort avec un
charrues sur votre pellicule à les en
europe et dit à tout le monde ce que
nous voulons une république islamique
afghane indépendante sans russe ni
américain où toutes les religions toutes
les opinions seront respectées dit lors
de nous aider car si aujourd'hui les
russes sont en afghanistan
demain il pourrait bien aller chez vous
need leur enfin que la mort ne nous fait
pas peur
dehors la décision d'attaquer les
charrues s'est déjà répandue ce camp qui
était vide à notre arrivée s'est
transformé en un rassemblement de
guerrier la consigne a été transmises de
bouche à oreille et en quelques minutes
tous les moudjahidine se sont retrouvés
pour se préparer à la tacc cartouches
neuves achetées au prix de lourds
sacrifices vieux fusil de chasse
voilà l'armé qui depuis plus de trois
mois se bat contre les troupes
soviétiques
pour tous ces combattants
l'affrontement direct avec l'ennemi est
totalement exclu face aux chars aux
hélicoptères vos mig
ces hommes sont condamnés à employer la
vieille technique de la guérilla des
coups de main et la disparition
immédiate dans les montagnes qu'ils
connaissent bien
on l'a dit et redit mais c'est vrai que
leur meilleure arme résident encore dans
leur foi pour eux la mort n'est pas la
fin de la vie au contraire est un
moudjahidine combattants de la fois pour
une guerre sainte contre des communistes
contre des actes et la mort n'est que la
possibilité d'accéder directement au
paradis
aux côtés d'al là
dès lors on comprend mieux leur
engagement et leur témérité un peu folle
au combat au mieux ils pourront tuer un
infidèle au pire
l'éternité leur est assurée c'est
pourquoi avant chaque bataille
les moudjahidine font leurs ablutions
dans un endroit délimité par quelques
pierres à l'une des extrémités du camp
et se réunissent ensuite pour prier un
acte au moins aussi important que
l'armement
c'est essentiellement de la prière qu'il
vous retirer leurs forces pour aller se
battre
aum
cette offre les manifs hamida
ah ah
tous ces hommes sont des hasards à ses
litanies à l'adresse du tout puissant
elles sont caractéristiques de l'islam
chiite qui est la religion dominante en
hasard 'achat'
tel n'est pas le cas du reste de
l'aghanistan qui est sunnite depuis des
siècles à chaque épreuve qu'a traversé
le pays le gouvernement de kaboul c'est
toujours retourner contre ses hasards à
ces afghans qui avait le tort de ne pas
appartenir à l'islam sunnite
aujourd'hui encore les hazaras sont la
cible privilégiée des nouveaux maîtres
de l'aghanistan
cette disparité ce divorce entre chiites
et sunnites
existent aussi dans ce camp au moment où
les hasards à était en pleine prière
à l'autre extrémité du temps une autre
cérémonie avait lieu une danse guerrière
exécutés par les pachtouns à leur
manière le dossier se prépare à la
guerre
mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper tous ces
hommes vont se retrouver unis au combat
contre un ennemi commun les soviétiques
la danse terminé les pachtouns sont
prêts pour l'attack la prière exécuter
les hasards à part également à l'assaut
des chars russes
l'offensive de printemps commence en
afghanistan
dans mes amis j'ai l'impression que ce
qui frappe le plus son regard dans ce
reportage c'est le côté dérisoire de
l'organisation et du matériel dont
disposent ces rebelles face aux troupes
soviétiques
vous avez raison je crois qu'il faut
remarquer trois choses d'abord le
caractère dérisoire effectivement de
cette résistance afghane à la limite ce
reportage pourrait être une réponse à
toutes ces affirmations selon lesquelles
la résistance afghane au secret des
armes américaines chinoises ou
pakistanaise
je crois qu'il n'en est rien ce
reportage est assez clair là dessus pour
la même raison et parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens de nous protéger les
moudjahidine nous ont formellement
interdit de nous approcher des chars
soviétiques il est évident et c'est l'un
des chefs de la résistance ne le disais
il est évident que nous les savons
beaucoup plus en racontant leurs
conditions de vie quand elle a essayé de
filmer des chars soviétiques la deuxième
chose à remarquer c'est que malgré tous
les moudjahidines existent ils se
battent aujourd'hui en afghanistan avec
des moyens dérisoires c'est vrai mais
après tout toutes les rébellions dans le
monde entier ont commencé comme cela et
si cela continue
c'est mon troisième point la chine les
etats unis d'autres vont commencer à les
aider réellement à les armer et à partir
de ce moment là je crois tout pourrait
devenir possible merci pour terminer
sans transition le sport tennis le
tournoi de monte-carlo continue avec la
victoire cet après-midi du suédois john
buck a battu l'argentin clair en quart
de finale et en deux sets
il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 16 le 11 et
le 20 je n'ai pas encore les rapports
nous l'aurons dans le dernier journal
qui vous sera présenté en fin de
programme par pear alain demain invités
d'antenne 2 me dit monsieur jacques
rigaud qui est le pdg de la station de
radio périphérique comme on dit rtl je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
antenne 2 bonsoir